in washington dc
there's a big pride parade there are
pride parades
everywhere throughout the entire country
throughout the entire
world it's throughout it's throughout
the western world at this point
during one of these pride parades
there was a man
running down the street
he appears to have had
breast implants or some kind of
chemically induced breasts or something
and he ends up twerking on a policeman
you can see him there
he's strutting in front of a side that
says european union for lgbt plus rights
he
he appears to have something like
breasts or any areas twerking on a cop
in there
[Applause]
there's someone waving the
european flag oh and the people waving
the european flag seem to be very young
and there are plenty of kids there out
in the crowd
and the man with the breasts
twerking on the cop and the cop just
runs away
in a more sane age the cop would
put this guy in cuffs and take him
either to jail or or more likely a
lunatic asylum and say something's going
wrong in your life buddy and we got to
figure it out so that you don't do stuff
like this but the guy in the
in the street with the
some kind of augmented breasts had demon
horns on like little devil horns and you
you do notice this a lot there's a lot
of overlap here between the radical
sexual revolutionary stuff
and demonic imagery sinful imagery
satanic imagery and i imagine that the
activists on the the sexual revolution
side will just write this off and say oh
we're just being provocative oh it's not
we don't really believe in the devil oh
we don't really but i don't how come
this this imagery keeps cropping up all
the time
and the twi and it's so brazen now and
it's so obscene i
if obscenity laws have any meaning
whatsoever and we still have obscenity
laws on the books if they have any
meaning whatsoever
a demon horn wearing dude with breasts
wearing a thong jiggling on a police
officer in front of kids i think has to
count
right and if that doesn't count
we don't we don't effectively have
obscenity laws anywhere
in this country
or throughout the western world
in idaho there is a pride parade
this took place in corridalin
idaho
police arrested 31 members of a group
called patriot front
this group the 31 people in patriot
front were found in a u-haul vehicle
near the pride parade
and they were just there in their
vehicle but the cops said it is clear to
us based on the gear that the
individuals had with them the stuff they
had in their possession the u-haul with
them along with the paperwork that was
seized from them that they came to riot
downtown
so notice here this group patriot front
fed front i don't know i've i haven't
really heard very much about this group
and whenever i hear about it
it's in this way that seems to be
actively promoted by the establishment
media and i'm sort of skeptical that the
group even exists beyond something
thought up in langley or
quantico but regardless let's say it is
real this far right radical group they
were arrested
for
potentially planning
to riot
blm very often doesn't get arrested for
actually rioting and burning things down
and killing people but this far right
group
gets arrested for potentially planning
to riot
so for a potential crime
at a pride parade
where real crimes are taking place
at at the very least the crime of
obscenity at the very least the crime of
public disturbance at the very least the
crime of indecent exposure and indecent
exposure toward kids that are kids at
all of these pride parades
and yet the cops never arrest the
weirdos like the
like the demon horn wearing guy with his
breasts hanging out jiggling on a cop in
front of kids they never arrest those
guys for committing actual crimes but
then they rush in we got to send in the
swat team we got to send in the the
fbi to go arrest
this
minor right-wing group
that may or may not be real in the first
place for potentially i'm not defending
this group if it's real or not patriot
front fo arrest them if you want if
they've committed a crime
but how come
we focus all
of the resources in law enforcement on
punishing
right-wing people for crimes that they
may be committed maybe didn't commit
maybe plan to commit maybe don't but we
don't ever punish
leftists who are actually committing
crimes
in the same place at the same time doing
the same thing
doesn't make sen seems to me we should
focus more of our resources on arresting
the groomers
on arresting the weirdos the the people
frankly it would be for their own good i
don't think the guy in the in the demon
horns with the boobs hanging out i don't
think that guy is living his best life i
don't think he's got it all together i
don't think he's flourishing okay
but we have said no that is flourishing
that's the that's what we should all
want fox freaking news is saying if your
kid
if your kid is two years old and can't
even speak yet
we've got it you've got to trans your
kid
and in that fox segment by the way the
mother would you believe it the mother
has a book deal talking about all this
this creepy mother who says oh yes
before my daughter could speak before my
i'm sorry before my son
could speak he told me that he is
totally a boy and not a girl which she
obviously is
even fox news promoting that stuff
all of that is totally fine but
we've got to focus all of our attention
on the threat from the far right radical
insurrectionists goodness gracious if we
don't stop them a midwestern dad might
drink a coors light in the capital
rotunda could you imagine
it brings me back to this question is
pelosi right
is pelosi right when she says
transvestitism is what america is all
about
no
not if you ask the majority of americans
not if you ask the founding fathers
they'd be rolling over in their graves
but there is something
weird about america with this issue
the western world broadly kind but it's
america in particular has this you
remember the french
a few months ago
macron said we don't want wokeness
wokeness is very bad it's a cultural
export from america and it's poisoning
everything we don't want it we don't do
wokeness in in france which is one of
the most left-wing places in the western
world but they said we don't want that
so what is it about america i think it's
that in america
there is this idea
that you can be whatever you want to be
in america it doesn't matter how you're
born what you look like what your skills
are even you every every child born in
america
can be the president of the united
states
any child if he really puts his mind to
it can be an astronaut and each you can
be anything and there's something
nice about this idea in america
but it isn't true
there's a lot of freedom in america
there's a lot of freedom of mobility
there's so much opportunity go west
young man go strike your fortune there
is
there is some truth to the american
dream
but that's not absolute you can't do
whatever you want to do i will never be
a basketball player i never could have
been a basketball player i was born
with certain limitations
okay when you are a child of the mezzo
giorno of southern italy okay and you're
not six foot seven and you're not from
the most athletic race of people in the
world then you're just not i'm never
gonna play in the nba that was a limit
that i had okay but i've got other
limits beyond that
i've got limits of nature of biology i'm
never going to be a girl i'm never going
to be a woman
i can i can really want to be a woman
but i i can't be
there are natural limits here the reason
that
that america worked for so long
is because we had this really
inspirational idea of you can do
pretty much whatever you want to do but
we had a culture a tradition of limits
and we had a religion
christianity that told us that we have
responsibilities we have a moral order
that we have to respect we have natural
boundaries we have to respect and we've
got to
to give ourselves over to god's will and
cooperate with his grace
as america has become
less christian still religious but it's
less christian to be a much more
leftist transgenderist
individualist whatever
all of those limits are gone and it's
just like what
you can have beautiful poetry when you
respect a few simple boundaries meter
rhyme
really basic stuff
when you get rid of those boundaries you
get slam poetry which is the death of
art it's the worst thing ever that's
that's where we are i think this this
might be
the issue we need to recognize that
nancy pelosi's idea that the great thing
about america is is dancing around in
drag the great thing about america is
the freedom quote unquote to dance
around like a transvestite
no that isn't it we know that that's not
it we know that's not what the founding
fathers thought we know that that's not
what anybody thought in this country
until five minutes ago for goodness
sakes transvestitism was illegal in much
of america for much of the 19th century
and parts of the 20th century including
san francisco
so we know that's not what america is
about if your idea of america
is that that's what america is about
then your idea is wrong we need to go
back to history to our tradition to our
actual culture and say where did we go
wrong where when you're twerking on the
cops and grooming and transiting the
kids something has gone wrong i'm so
glad you liked that clip now ring ding
bing bada bada bing bong subscribe to
the michael knowles show get all of the
notifications for every single video
then head on over to spotify stitcher
google play apple podcast wherever
myspace i don't care wherever subscribe
to the michael knowles show leave a
five-star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]